what's up everyone this is Anthony
papiano
most of you know me as pump you're
listening to off the chain
simply the best podcasting crypto let's
kick this thing off Dan Conway is the
author of confessions of a crypto
millionaire my unlikely escape from
corporate America in this conversation
we discussed his backstory the process
of writing the book the ups and downs of
crypto market volatility why Dan cashed
out thirteen million dollars in January
2018 and what he is doing from an
investment standpoint today I really
enjoyed this conversation and I hope you
do as well
skirt school want to know who has the
best URL crypto com
that's right crypto com there are crypto
platform with one goal mother in mass
adoption that's why we're all here we're
trying to get crypto in every wallet
crypto calm is helping people do that
through buying earning lending and card
payment everything you could want at
crypto calm go help your boy out tell
them pomp sense you download the app or
visit crypto calm pumps got you always
everyone to get into mining and didn't
know how don't worry your boy pops
gotcha everybody got some electricity
and Wi-Fi all you got to do is go to
coin mine comm you buy a coin mine it's
like an Xbox or a Playstation that helps
you turn your electricity into Bitcoin
that's right
you purchase it it shows up at your
doorstep you pull it out of the box you
plug it in connect to your Wi-Fi five
minutes or less you're mining Bitcoin
all you have to do is control it from
the mobile app they provide and then you
receive over-the-air updates that add
new coins and new features on a
consistent basis kind of like how Tesla
does over-the-air updates and updates
the car software just you're updating
your coin mind consumer mining made easy
that's right
go to coin mine calm tell them pomp
setya and thank me later as many of you
know crypto investors store their
digital assets on exchanges or in cold
storage for long-term safekeeping
however this strategy doesn't help them
grow their investment holdings or build
overall wealth with the new block by
interest account users can now securely
store their Bitcoin or ether at block 5
receive 6% annual interest paid monthly
and cryptocurrency 6% is an absurdly
high rate it's the best rate in the
industry I highly suggest you go check
out block 5 calm / pump again that's
block 5 calm / pop to sign up and start
earning crypto today if you follow
Bitcoin and crypto you've probably heard
of eToro they're the world's number one
social trading platform and I love it
they've got more than 10 million other
traders that love it - and guess what
they just launched the United States
eToro offers access to the world's most
popular crypto currencies including
Bitcoin etherium and others with the
smartest trading tools and the ability
to connect with the best traders around
the world there's no better place to
build your perfect portfolio if you're
new to Bitcoin and crypto you can test
the waters with their $100,000 virtual
trading feature but if you're more
experienced you can create custom
technical charts and use eToro social
fees to inform your trading decisions
they've got transparent fees and so you
never miss out they also have an
easy-to-use application available on
iPhone Android or any web browser you
can get started today in just a few
clicks
at each or Oh calm again that's eToro
comm get VIP access to Bitcoin and
crypto markets today Anthony pomp leon o
is a partner at Morgan Creek digital all
pinyons expressed by pump or his guests
on this podcast are solely their
opinions and do not reflect the opinions
of Mourne Creek digital or Morgan Creek
Capital Management you should not treat
any opinion expressed by pomp as a
specific inducement to make a particular
investment or follow a particular
strategy but only as an expression of
his opinion this podcast is for
informational purposes only
alright guys bang bang I've got a very
special guest here today Dan Conway the
author of the new book Confessions of a
crypto millionaire might unlikely escape
from corporate America I'm super excited
to have this conversation
he's got a wild [ __ ] story I'll just
give you a little teaser from the back
page of the book it says when the
Financial Times interviewed Dan Conway
for her story about cryptocurrency
millionaires he told them the
unvarnished truth quote I invested
because I wanted the underdogs to win
for once losers like me who didn't make
the rules and didn't
the money we'd been forced to tweet
corporate philanthropy hashtags and we
weren't going to take it anymore
bang bang alright man thanks so much for
for coming in and doing this how how are
things going so far it's going great
thanks Tom for having me I really
appreciate the opportunity so things are
going great so far the book has been you
know well-received I I spent two years
on it trying to capture everything that
happened to me and try to make sense of
you know the 2015 through the beginning
of 2018 and so it's I'm happy to hear
that readers are responding to different
different aspects of the story that's
that's good you don't want to write a
book for two years and everyone says it
sucks so hopefully knock on wood that's
not the case yet or hopefully ever for
sure so let's start with your story
right kind of let's go before crypto
what was going on and and kind of what
were you doing and then we can get into
some of the corporate America issues
sure so I was working at a big company
which for legal reasons I call acne and
in the book and basically there's one of
the largest corporations in the world
and I had worked my way up this was like
my big break you know I was I started at
this company when I was about 40 I think
I was 40 exactly and I so I'd work my
way up for 20 you know 18 years in
corporate America and I had had found
myself and it's sort of a lower
executive rank you know where that's
where the big money's supposed to be and
finally I was gonna you know be able to
make it I lived in Silicon Valley and my
wife and I were raising three kids so we
were not poor by any stretch but we were
financially stretched for sure after the
2008 Great Recession we lost our equity
line on our home we were kind of like
using credit cards some months to get by
so again most people on the planet would
want to be in my position but the
strains of working in a corporate job
that I soon found I was sort of ill
suited for we're really growing on me
for sure and so we were talking
beforehand about this idea of you know
some people just aren't cut out for the
corporate executive world maybe talk a
little bit about some of the things that
you realized you know over the years and
you know some of the personality stuff
as well
yeah you know I so I when I had finally
gotten to this what I considered like
you know fairly high up perch I was
still basically a middle manager but I
could you know call myself an executive
and I you know primped and preened to my
LinkedIn profile and all that the
problem was once I got there there was
this this thing you needed to eat to
stay and thrive in your position and
especially to rise up further and it was
executive presence you know acne like
many companies they believe in kind of
what I've called like the cult of the
leader that you know this these people
with these great leadership qualities
that will drive organizations and lead
us all to greater wealth and happiness
and I I just could not do it man I I
could fake it well but when you get to
that that position that I was at I
needed it to I I didn't have the skills
to maintain it so I would you know I
would crack a bad joke I'd get insecure
get quiet in the meeting or else I get
you know kind of manic and speak a
little too much nothing extreme like no
one was gonna call the hospital and take
me out on a stretcher but when there's
that very narrow window of you know
where you need to show your leadership
qualities I just couldn't seem to hit it
I just kept bouncing off of it for
certain and I think that a lot of it
probably is you know its personality
driven but it's also people get bored
right that there's a lot of folks who
might call it the the trap right and the
reason why I call it the trap is I talk
to people on an almost daily basis who
work a corporate job as people who are
listening to this right now who are in
this situation and they are you know
late 30s into their mid 40s and then
sometimes even into their 50s and
they're sitting there saying you know
how the hell did I get here
right I married I got kids I work in
corporate America and this is not the
life that I had dreamed of or envisioned
and they feel trapped and the the risk
is if they make some big move or some
big decision it could not only disrupt
their lives and potentially be
detrimental but if they've got to worry
about their significant other their kids
kind of all these things that you know
again they trap you into a certain life
yeah that that's exactly right and I'm
not like an overly literary guy but
there's one quote by um
that always stuck with me it's men and
women living lives of quiet desperation
and and that's the way I felt in
corporate America and you know
especially after the Great Recession we
were all just happy to have a job but
you can take a step back all the studies
show that you know I think it's like 75%
of people are unhappy with the teamwork
and the experience at their job and I
have these stats in the book and and
we've kind of accepted that as like a
sort of a deep sliver in our heel and
you know I'm at the age now where you
know like late 40s sadly like people are
like a very few people outliers are
starting to drop off from cancer and
brain tumors and stuff you know that's
one of the blessings curses of Facebook
is you know like people in your outer
circle suddenly and you just realize
like you know you only mean it sounds
corny but you can only have one life if
you're sitting behind a desk doing
something you're miserable miserable at
even if you have enough money to take
your family out to dinner on the
weekends you know is it worth it and and
that was kind of where I was at for sure
and so let's dig in a little bit on the
on the crypto Bitcoin and ether stuff
when is the first time that you ever
heard of Bitcoin or ether I so I first
heard I first heard about Bitcoin I in
like 2012 or something like that and
like many others I thought it sounded
like total [ __ ] and of course I was
just like working my trying to trying to
make it still at this company and the
handwriting was on the wall and I didn't
see it but it was when I was really
having problems at my job it was it was
a period in in 2015 that I came across
an article on Bitcoin and Bitcoin was
about 300 then and yeah it was just
simply the thought what if it goes up
again and you know it was pure greed
pure you know investment like
speculative energy that got me kind of
going and learning about crypto and I
loved Bitcoin and the thing that just
blew me away
in addition to the spy novel stuff like
Satoshi no one knows who he is worth
billions all the you know the darknet
stuff and Silk Road stuff while was a
big part of the story back then stole I
mean still a part of the story today but
but it really just got me and and and
then I quickly learned about I always
loved dick
but I quickly learned of etherium and
the thing that that became really
interesting once I learned about
aetherium was two things one is a
theorem hadn't popped yet I think when I
first learned about ether it was at
about $3 or $4 so it was like this new
emerging coin and you know back then of
course everyone thought well you we all
missed bitcoins so you know at 300 400
bucks like too late for that one so it
drew me in my speculative side to ether
because it hadn't popped yet but then
and then this was like what made things
really interesting was it was also the
promise of decentralization and the idea
that and folks in aetherium we're
talking about this more than Bitcoin how
etherium and smart contracts and
decentralized block chains could disrupt
the court could disrupt disrupt
centralized corporations centralized
organizations things like that and and
you know no one was saying it was gonna
happen tomorrow although they tried to
do it almost relatively tomorrow with
the Dow which we can talk about but it
was that concept and and then I started
to go deep deep deep down the you know
the rabbit hole and it was like I was
fueled by both the speculative you know
greedy guy and also though this guy that
was like struggling in his career and I
like immediately saw the potential
benefits of decentralization in terms of
like wiping away the bureaucracy the
chains of command the [ __ ] phony
corporate culture and you know I I
wasn't naive to think it was gonna
happen tomorrow but I I saw that with
Bitcoin working you could never uninvent
blockchain and so that's why I started
to go so deep on on ether because of
sort of that promise of decentralized
organizations and what's interesting to
me is you know as part of the story and
in the book it's not like you were
sitting around with millions of dollars
in cash and you made a decision that hey
I'm gonna put one percent of my net
worth into this speculative asset and
let's see what happens maybe talk a
little bit about you know kind of where
you were financially at the time what
decisions you made and you know what the
thought process was leading up to those
decisions yeah I mean so the book the
books titled confessions of a crypto
millionaire as you know and it's got a
kind of a click Beatty title but that
tested better than anything else and
it's the thing that I'm hoping brings
mainstream people and to learn about you
know
the deeper the deeper goals and and of
blockchain aware the the movement and
what's happening with all of it but the
so where I was at where I was at
basically at the time that that this all
happened was was I was we were we were
just just making it financially we were
doing fine and then oh the reason why I
mentioned that about the title was that
you know it's it's the book is not meant
to be a rebuttal to people to say I got
lucky not at all it's a response to it
though because something like this
doesn't just happen for no reason and
there was like a lot of factors that
that that occurred in my life that
allowed this to happen and a lot of
people out there probably other
listeners have similar factors now and
they might in the future but I just find
the whole thing interesting like how do
normal people quote unquote normal
people like go so deep in this stuff and
at the time though when when I got in we
one of the big blessings was we had a
windfall on you know we were basically
my mother sold her house and gave us 50
grand my wife's startup got bought by
Microsoft and she lost her job but she
got like 25 grand and then at my company
I had some options that finally best and
I had like another 20 or 25 grand so
we're like a like a hundred grand total
and it was like right around the time
that I was starting to like spend four
or five hours a night like no joke after
work after the kids are asleep listening
to podcasts reading on reddit on Twitter
just like trying to soak it all in so I
had a decision to make about you know
about what I would do with this money
and you know the other thing we haven't
mentioned is you know I like I'm an
outlier in a lot of different ways one
of them is that I have a massively
addictive personality and I had been
recovered at the time that we had this
hundred grand and I was deciding whether
to invest it I had been recovered for
let me see three years from pills and
and an alcoholism and I got deep into
oxys and vicodins and I was leaving my
corporate job and go into pill Hill in
the Tenderloin and buying these pills
and you know I was clearly unhappy and
combined with an addictive personality
at the time but anyway I say that
because I was in charge of our
investment
investments for me and my wife my wife
doesn't like to talk about money you
know they just don't talk about it in
her family like most families so I had
in my mind I convinced myself that I
sort of had the ability to take this
money which we were using as a security
blanket because my job was shaky and and
and do something and do something you
know to make a plunge to so to speak for
sure and so when you're sitting in that
seat and you're kind of doing all this
research you know there's an element of
okay I'm going to invest in this here's
why I want to do that and again you know
I always caveat these conversations with
none of this is investment advice none
of this is a suggestion for anyone else
to go do something I think this is just
your story right you literally wrote a
book on it and kind of as to you know
what your decision-making was but but
describe kind of what happened when
exactly you invested and then what
transpired in the months afterwards so I
I don't know the exact moment but there
a flip switched in my head I had a
tipping point and it was like you know
during some crappy meeting on a Tuesday
morning and I just I I just I just knew
I was ready so I folded the papers and
my and my coat and I walked down to
Wells Fargo the bank that had pulled our
equity line eight years before and I
walked in and I started a wire and I
wired a hundred thousand dollars all
hundred thousand dollars to Gemini they
were like the first big one to offer
ether and that was the coin that I was
most interested in and so you know I
just decided I was ready I was making
the plunge you only live once scared but
excited and I looked down at my phone
and there's a text from my wife and it
said what the [ __ ] is this and it was an
alert obviously from Wells Fargo letting
her know that all hundred thousand
dollars was being sent to something
called Gemini which she had never heard
of of course so the rest of that day
sucked and and we went home and we
talked about it and then I you know she
was mad obviously we spent a lot of time
on it she was not at all interested in
it at least she did later say she
noticed that I had changed you know I'd
kind of been you know just sort of
slumped over for even
though I'd gotten sober and was healthy
I was just so miserable she-she humored
me a bit and then I go into the book we
made a deal that that shows you know
that shows we have a good marriage and
it's weird and that's interesting like
most marriages but ultimately I was able
to put that hundred grand in so I I
proudly went down to the bank and it was
early June 2016 and I bought a hundred
thousand dollars worth of ether and then
on my birthday about two weeks later on
June 18th that's when the Dow hack
happened and we were walking to the
breakfast spot and my phone started
blowing up because I had all these
alerts for you know people I followed on
Twitter and and read it and all this
kind of stuff and we lot we eventually
we eventually like lost a large part of
our stack I tried to make I tried to
make a disastrous trade I thought I
thought okay this is clearly gonna go
lower you know I wasn't even worried
that ultimately it would be okay I was
such a true believer I mean I just I was
certain I don't know you know I that was
just how I felt at the time and so I
thought I could you know just like a
famous mistake I just had a lot more at
stake I just thought that I could I
could sell and buy back low or and you
know what happened like right right when
I sold it started going back up I panic
buy back in lost 25% of my stack and
then literally right when I got back in
it started to finally recover and go up
so I ended up losing like it's in the
book like thirty five percent of my
stack something like that right off the
bat I mean it's classic right it's the
whole you know people buy high sell low
when they should be doing the opposite
but it's also I don't know a person who
came into the cryptocurrency markets and
it doesn't go through some degree of
what you're describing right
it's a highly volatile asset it is very
news driven at times and there's a very
easy access to buying and selling if
you're already on one of these platforms
and so a little bit with the click of a
button you can make an emotional
decision which leads to in some cases
bad decision making over a long period
of time that's exactly right and you
know it reminded me of being at a
blackjack table where you you have 18
and the dealer gets 21 or you have a 12
you know you're going to
Queen when you hit I mean just like it
you trading crypto for me I didn't know
what I was doing I didn't know TA and
and more importantly though it was
stupid because I was really a long-term
play I mean I I never I figured in a few
years once once there's mainstream use
for Bitcoin and ether that at the time
was my calculus like this stuff can't be
uninvented I I mean just like it is
today you see how much developments
happening and I figured that it would be
a play for two or three years so I ended
up getting fired for my job and and then
and I you know document that all in the
book and then I am and then and then I
started a PR practice in crypto and I
worked with companies like bit go and
and and some others some other projects
and but you know at the time either and
and crypto in general Bitcoin and all
the rest were had not recovered yet and
so I was wondering you know like okay
I'm gonna try to make it as a PR person
here I'm not sure if this investments
gonna pay off any time soon and it was
um it was becoming a bit of a strain
that can I I'm gonna mention what what
happened then of course so so things
were going well and crypto and the
deeper I got into and I'm I was brushing
up against people like Eric Bohr he's
and Andreas Antonopoulos these were like
super heroes to me you know what I mean
like I I just knew them from the virtual
world and so I was having a blast
obviously you know I'm listen I'd never
done on the cutting edge of anything I'm
like you know I'm like a fine individual
but I was like 45 years old and working
in a corporate job and you know III was
it felt very much like if you read a
story about Steve Jobs and Apple in the
valley and people see him at different
places it had breakfast with him and all
these you know Scott McNealy all these
big Titans like before they were big and
not just them but their whole their
industries were so small you could you
could like become involved and work with
and collaborate with these people before
they became kind of like legends of
business and you know I'm a homer for
the industry I absolutely believe that
that's going to happen and in some ways
it already has so it was super fun for
me and the thing about it though was
that was spending so much time in the
industry that I and I was trying to work
the numbers on my investment which at
this point by the end of 2016 was down
about 65 70 %
think again I have all the exact numbers
in the book but I became convinced I
became convinced this is I i document
how this happened
but I I really kind of went off the deep
end and I'm like youth like pop said
like you said dude don't do what I did
this is this is my story is meant to
give people an idea about how they
handle risk it's a fun read I think it's
and it also as a way to learn about the
industry but it's not like a how-to
guide but for better or not I went I
went way deeper I went and I my wife had
by the way and did not want to talk
about crypto anymore it's like literate
all I talked about and so and so she
said well just do what you want and so I
ended up going into our home equity line
we have gotten that back from Wells
Fargo a year two prior and I put another
$250,000 into ether when it was about
eight nine ten eleven dollars I had to
buy slowly so now I was in three hundred
and fifty K at the end of 2016 and so
for those that don't know ether
specifically was caught I was called
five to ten dollars and it continued at
that you know that kind of price and
pace for a while and then in I think it
was like March of 2017 is I remember
vividly because I was really paying
attention it went from ten to thirty to
a hundred by like the end of May right
it was almost like a 10x in a very short
period of time
crazy started in February and really
picked up in March and we were on a trip
so part of the deal by men with my wife
was we won't we had to take we we we had
to take all these family vacations like
like extravagant family vacations like
that was her part of the deal she was
focused on the family and so we were we
like went to the aloni and Hawaii we
went to porta viar-toe we went to Ching
Katara Italy we went to Costa Rica I
mean I'm not kidding it was it was
insane at the same time we had this big
investment it was not a smart thing to
do but I would I would have done
anything anything to buy crypto at that
time I would have agreed to anything so
so basically we're in port of IATA and
we were at this
busting resort it was actually like
beautiful views but horrible food and
there was this fajita bar and they had
like you had to scoop your own meat like
your raw meat onto your plate then you
give it to them and they cook it it was
like totally disgusting and and so that
night I was I was I woke up at like
11:00 p.m. I was like foaming at the
mouth I was puking I've never been this
sick like I thought I was gonna die I
could not stop puking so I ended up like
by myself jumping in a cab at like 3:00
in the morning in Puerto Vallarta during
going to downtown Puerto Vallarta to buy
Dramamine and that's when that's when
earth started to pop and and when it
started to pop it was like it was like
seeing Santa Claus in the flesh like I
thought it would happen I knew it was
gonna happen but it was it was so crazy
how quickly that it went up I mean you
know this is a crypto listenership
people know they lived through it and
and I believe it's gonna happen again
for sure by the way but it was crazy and
I remember that time being like I was in
a cab like wanting to puke and I was
gonna like puke all over this guy's cab
and I didn't know like what the
situation was he's like gonna kick my
ass or something like I don't even know
where I was I was like in some back
alley of Puerto Vallarta but I didn't
care because I've made like by the time
I got in that cab I'd make like $70,000
or something insane like that and it was
just this feeling that like holy [ __ ]
our life is going to change and it was
mostly euphoria but there was also this
like underlying like tension anxiety and
fear and I've talked to a lot of people
who have been through this and it's a
very common feeling because your whole
world is shifting not unlike when you
win the lottery
people say it's very destabilizing look
and the crazy part to me of this whole
thing is you know you kind of made an
early bet you actually failed to some
degree right you lost some of the
investment you double down the ether
price starts to explode you know
newsflash it went all the way to $1400
at one point so from 10 to 14 hundred is
a pretty big increase there what was
kind of the journey from you know pre
February March 2017 all the way to the
at the top of that price point of $1400
and what did you do along the way
skirt school want to know who has the
best URL crypto comm that's right crypto
comm their crypto platform with one goal
mother mass adoption that's why we're
all here
we're trying to get crypto in every
wallet crypto comm is helping people do
that through buying earning lending and
card payment everything you could want
at crypto comm go help your boy out
tell them pomp sense you download the
app or visit crypto comm pumps got you
always everyone to get into mining and
didn't know how don't worry your boy
pops gotcha everybody got some
electricity and Wi-Fi all you got to do
is go to coin mine comm you buy a coin
mine it's like an Xbox or a PlayStation
that helps you turn your electricity
into Bitcoin that's right you purchase
it it shows up at your doorstep you pull
it out of the box you plug it in connect
to your Wi-Fi five minutes or less
you're mining Bitcoin all you have to do
is control it from the mobile app they
provide and then you receive
over-the-air updates that add new coins
and new features on a consistent basis
kind of like how Tesla does over-the-air
updates and updates the car software
just you're updating your coin mind
consumer mining made easy that's right
go to coin mine calm
tell them pomp Sencha and thank me later
one more word from our sponsor blocked
by their new interest account allows you
to securely deposit your Bitcoin or
Ethernet block by and receive six
percent annual interest paid monthly and
cryptocurrency
this rate actually compounds so you
receive a 6.2 percent APY which is very
attractive given the alternatives so you
can actually take your Bitcoin you can
deposit it with block Phi and get paid
an interest rate of 6% in return go
check out block 5 comm slash pump again
block 5 comm / pump to sign up and start
earning interest on your crypto today
what was kind of the journey from you
know pre February March 2017 all the way
to the at the top of that price point of
$1,400 and what did you do along
yeah it was it was you know I was like
the year of magical thinking I mean it
was I had like zero frame of reference
to handle what I went through zero it
was you know I like some days I would I
would like there were days where I was
up like a million dollars you know and
and and it was it was like there was I'm
half days where I was up a million
dollars and and basically I became like
this profit in the community for crypto
and you know I talked about my flip side
in the book and that's what didn't let
me succeed in corporate America it's
part of me and it's insecure and it's
also as illusions of grandeur and you
know say this stupid stuff and and you
know it's just like the reason why I
never had executive presence but it was
a part of that that part of my
personality that addictive greedy kind
of like chip on your shoulder guy was a
part of was right there with me it right
along with the like the smart like
inspired side the part that could see
the future this con think so I was like
the perfect communicator I mean it just
seeped out of me and I'm sure pomp you
can wreck you you recognize some of this
to just from talking crypto but when
it's in this kind of a bull run man like
I people wanted to hear it and I wanted
to talk about it and it wasn't my
intention to get him to invest but I was
just like the perfect communicator I
would share anecdotes about my story I
would talk about projects I would talk
about price movement like one good
example of what it was and this wasn't
just a reflection of what was going on
with me but at the time I mean it was
all anyone could talk about was crypto I
mean people were making millions
millions millions it with the news
cycles now we forget so soon like not we
the crypto folks that are on this
podcast but but people like in the
general population but like I met with
my tax guys like seventy one years old
you know I had this guy he was great guy
like family friend and he started off
the meeting he had heard from my brother
I'd made a bunch of money I think I was
up like $900,000 or something at that
point and and and he had started out the
meeting like tell me listen I had this
guy he wants you know invested in this
watch company and the guy said he'd make
millions and all this kind of stuff and
I was like uh-huh well when it was my
turn I just like stood and delivered man
and by the end of the meeting he told me
he was going to put in ten grand
- ether he called me the next day to say
he put in 20 grand and it was just like
I had people like literally knocking on
my door I had people like hitting me up
on Facebook Twitter reddit and the
problem was there was a lot ups and
downs during that year and I thought I
got hacked twice I you know I we didn't
get out there's just like ups and downs
I mean during that period people forget
during 17 it crashed down like 60% and I
hadn't taken out much of my investment
and so it was like I was on this drug I
mean was the most powerful drug I had
ever been on and I've been on oxys and
booze and and when when the price
dropped even if I was up on paper it was
like this sudden brutal withdrawals
it was completely insane and again this
is something I have a bunch of early
readers and this is something people can
relate to - it was just a phenomena that
is hard - it's it's there's not a lot of
examples of it you know it was it's such
a new thing these crazy crypto bull runs
so I got to ask though I think that a
lot of this you know we sit here and
we're enjoying the story because it ends
well and we'll get to that in a second
what do you think is the risks or if you
look back you're like look it was insane
for me to do X & Y or Z and and kind of
what's your advice to people today as
they look at this and and realizing it's
a highly volatile asset and some of the
challenges that come with the market
yeah that's that's that's a really good
point again I'm not a financial adviser
and all that but but basically what I
tell people today is first of all I tell
them like I'm kind of like Rip Van
Winkle as I mentioned you pump earlier
you know I like I I got out in I got out
70% of my stack at in early January 2018
lucky as hell fortunate I talked about
how that came about I had a financial
advisor a family friend and he helped me
through it because he was kind of my
straight man but you know it was for me
was more than an investment it was like
an identity it was a lifestyle like I
finally won you know what I mean like
all these crazy things aren't gonna show
up in like Peter Lynch's investment book
or Warren Buffett's like to you know
scribe at the beginning of the year or
whatever so what I tell people what I
tell people is
a you need you need you need to be
comfortable with risk those people that
don't do like a nine an eight or a nine
on the risk factor the Charles Schwab or
whatever be very careful about investing
crypto or only invest a very small
amount but if you're if you're someone
who likes risk
who's heavily into stocks who might even
have you know thought about like oh hey
let me put like five percent or 10
percent and something speculative like
you know currencies or derivatives or
you know stuff that you know more about
than I do pomp like it's hard for me to
see how you wouldn't put five or ten
percent of your money into crypto
because I just feel like and again this
is just me listen you heard my story I'm
a moon kid right I and I am still to
this day but it's hard for me to see all
these institutions all the development
all the partnerships all everything and
everyone's saying okay it's a volatile
asset and not think that it's gonna pop
up again there's just too much happening
and you know while some of the stuff
that people are working on they're good
they're areas gonna turn out to be
impossible there's gonna be some stuff
like that i I just have faith the
engineers are gonna be able to to pull
it off and the you the UI folks are
gonna be able to pull it off where
crypto Bitcoin ether some others becomes
more mainstream it's just hard for me to
see how it doesn't pop so if you have a
high risk mentality you know I think
it's a I think it's a great asset to buy
and I have zero
I have zero concerns about crypto long
term so if you're thinking about five or
ten years it's especially in my mind
something you need to seriously consider
all right so you hint it a little bit
towards what ends up happening in the
end what's kind of the end of the story
here when it comes to the crypto
investment yeah so it was we had we had
ups and downs and then you know read
around let me just think okay it was
fall 2017 and it looked like there for a
few months before that that you know
ether and Bitcoin kind of leveled off
then they started to fall there was like
a 40% decline and so it might have been
like okay this is that once in a decade
bull run it's over you know and and so
let's wait for the next big round who
knows when that'll be maybe five years
maybe 20 years and and then and then it
just like it was it turned out that was
the eye of the storm and
it just picked up it was like as I say
in the book it was like a UH it was like
a 9.0 earthquake with like an infinite
number of 9.0 aftershocks like I had
already documented I was up like I don't
know five or six million again numbers
on the book and and then it like doubled
in 30 days and then and then it kept
going up and I was up I was up like 15
million dollars and you know I I finally
I got a I got a critical email from my
financial adviser okay my family was in
Boston hanging out with my in-laws just
by chance it was early January they had
been there for New Year's
it was early January and I went for a
run one morning like at 5:30 I couldn't
sleep I could hardly sleep during this
period and I got an email from my
financial advisor who was also up early
because he's on New York hour so I'm in
the valley and it said you know he
listened he was something has changed in
crypto and and and in all my years of
experience this change could not be good
he said today I yesterday I received two
calls from 80 year old investors they
both asked me what I thought of Bitcoin
yesterday we also were gonna get our
photos done by a photographer for our
new analyst but he didn't show up he got
an I got an apology email later saying
that he had quit his job because he had
made two million dollars trading crypto
and it was a couple of examples and he
said in all my years of experience this
can't be a good thing he said I would
just because you know way more about it
than I do but I would be not doing my
duties as a financial adviser if I
didn't tell you my thoughts at this
point something started to click and for
me it wasn't like this was not based on
my rationale it was partly based on my
rational mind that it was part polished
parsh partially I was finally kind of
winning and so it was I went through
this morning of like excruciating
excruciating ly trying to decide whether
I was gonna sell because I mean at the
time here's the deal when we look back
oh god yeah January 2018 of course she
got a cell that's at the top no no no no
I was my subreddit at the time eath
trader the eath trade or subreddit I
mean talk was $5,000 ether I mean you
know even at that price it wouldn't be
as worth as much as Facebook so it was
not an easy decision
if I sold then I'd be up ten million
dollars but I mean the addict in my mind
said how [ __ ] good with 30 million B
I mean and and it was like then you're
talking like just some extravagant
wealth and even though wealth wasn't
necessarily what I was after I wanted to
quit my job I mean give me a break 30
million would I buy a newspaper start a
foundation I mean it was so but
thankfully thankfully I I was able to
pull away from that and I was able to
there's the Christmas cards on my mantle
you know and you know that was that was
part of it and also you know like like I
say in the book like it was it was not
just about my family at financial
security at all it was about me I wanted
to win I was like Walter White and that
famous scene from Breaking Brett
Breaking Bad man he wanted to win and
that was me but I did so and I sold
third 70% of my stack and I was sitting
on the couch I did it over the course
two or three hours now at that time the
Gemini ordered books I mean this was
like full-on mania I mean there was the
the the the the the green the green dot
there was it was full-on mania okay I
sold 10 million dollars again I forget
about the numbers but they're all in the
book I sold about 10 to 12 million no 13
million dollars of ether over the course
of three hours selling chunks of like
300 grand at a time and that ordered
book just gobble them right up gobble
them right up each time gobble them
right each time I sold it kept going up
six days later I sold at 9:15 six days
later ether hit 1,400 a few months later
it was back down to 400 and of course it
hit a low of 80 and you know bitcoins
mirrored that bitcoins done a lot better
but but but you know and then the other
thing I just mentioned pomp since I'm
going as far as a lot of people say like
my friends like they they're like well
how'd you turn that money or they're
like how did you how did you get that
cash like how did you turn that into US
dollars and like it couldn't have been
easier it was right on gem and I and by
the way I have it on the book I know
people don't like to say what exchange
they have or whatever but I'm doing it
anyway I got lots of lots of security in
place put it that way but but basically
I click the button wired it to my Wells
Fargo and the next day I walk down two
walls Fargo and
and it was all it was all right that was
online that day it was it was like it
was unbelievable
I'm as wild story right you essentially
took what ended up being $350,000 turned
it into 13 plus million dollars and you
did it with very little kind of
traditional training in finance you did
with you did it with very little you
know I think experience in terms of
investing etc and so it's funny to kind
of talk about it now right because you
did win in that sense but I do think
that there's a lot of people who will
listen to this and say you know that's
the one in the million story and for
sure I think you know you and I would
both agree that that's probably true as
you look at it today kind of how do you
think about investing in general right
do you still look just solely at crypto
markets do you look at other asset
classes or kind of that experience how
has that really guided you into what
what you're doing now with a from an
investment standpoint yeah and that you
know the thing was like I you know after
I before I got in a crypto I was I was
heavily into blogging and I've always
wanted to be a writer always liked to
write so I kind of like was heads down
for two years writing this book and you
know after I sold and I was like I threw
everything I had into this book and
multiple professional edits and just
just like everything you can do to make
a good book that people want to read
I've done that what it meant though was
that I was tracking crypto but I wasn't
like and all emotionally involved even
though I still have a pretty good stack
I sold 70 percent so I solved 30% of my
stack and I was not at all emotionally
involved though and I you know I pop up
with this book and I'm like going on
some of my sub brands hey everyone like
I you know I like I'm trying to make a
like a reddit post that people like will
click on so I'm like I made 13 million I
wrote a book about ether like here it is
about crypto and ether here it is and
like you know [ __ ] off [ __ ] you go away
Lambo boy blah blah blah I'm like what
these are my brothers what's going on
here and you know I just like totally
misplayed where people were at in the
market I knew it like at a rational
level but intellectually I kind of
got how hard it's been and I can't even
imagine like I mean I felt it a little
bit but not really nothing compared to
what people what people have been going
through so I anyway I just I just it
just dawned on me how I had not that the
level I was connected at before but
anyway so excuse me so for me I I'm
holding I'm holding crypto long term if
it goes if it skyrockets again I'll
probably sell half but I think like long
term is the real play and then you know
like before crypto my investments were
like very conventional
I had like index funds and things like
that and they were like you know they
were you know 70/30 for stocks or 60/40
stocks and bonds and I'm pretty much
back to that I mean it's like you know
it turns in it went from this like crazy
and thing insane thing that like took
over my soul back this little thing I
managed on a spreadsheet but you know I
I'm not so far as to think like the US
dollar or their traditional economy's
gonna collapse
I believe in crypto but I don't believe
enough to keep it all in crypto
obviously I mean it's not just me it's
like my kids and my wife and stuff but
but um but III do think long-term it's a
great play and and I just you know I I I
have a conventional investments
otherwise and they're managed by the
same guy who helped me get out of crypto
and he does well and it's ensemble
ensemble capital now oh it's that way I
sorry I shouldn't say any pitches here
or whatever so I don't know what their
financial rules are or whatever anyway
but yeah I mentioned them in the book
just in terms of this friendship and
guidance and all that you shout-out
friends that's loud alright before we
wrap up this amazing wild story but what
do you think is the the most important
company in crypto today okay I don't
have a solid answer here so I'll throw
out a company that I think that I think
is important but I like I said I have
not been studying as closely but I think
Gemini Gemini is important and I think I
think even though we think we're like
eons past you know the crazy like
everyone is associating crypto with dark
markets and buying heroin and like hit
men and stuff on online we're still not
entirely past that especially after 17
and there were so many scammers so many
lost so much money and I just know and
you all probably know from talking
your friends like people still think
it's risky it's dangerous and it is in a
lot of ways so I like Gemini because
even though they're kind of like squares
in some way but I'm talking about like
Krypto needs to be regulated and stuff
and this is a lot of what Mezrich talks
about in his book I still think there's
a need to like normalize this for the
normal population and I think those guys
have shown like they know how to do it
from a security perspective from a
branding perspective like they're very
like conservative for a crypto company
but um but I think that's what we need I
like the having like this blue chip
company run by the Winkle buy you know
and in New York and I think it's good
for that it's good for the industry to
have them for sure
so you're now writing and the book is
fantastic I highly suggest people go get
it what do you think is the most
important book you've ever read I would
say okay I would say the most important
important book I've ever read is there's
a book called the rise of Theodore
Roosevelt and I love Theodore Roosevelt
he was a moderate he happened to be a
Republican he was a moderate he took on
the corporations and was a monopoly
buster but this book documents how he
got there and it was like he's just like
the most amazing like young life he
grows like a sickly child and and like
one of his I think his mother died or
something like that and he just like
built himself through the years through
study through physical labor through
like courage and perseverance and and
then and then then the second half of
that book is all about like he was like
governor at 25 he was and he was just
like one of those people that like you
know the whole famous question if you
want to sit down with someone at dinner
who would you sit next to and he's just
like a fascinating guy but he was um he
was self built and and he was a very
progressive meaning he was open to new
ideas and that's like the thing I love
about Krypto is that you know this is
like this is just like the conceptual
stuff is so mind-blowing and it's it's
as much as the money and the greed
that's what draws a lot of us into the
space for sure what um
what do you think in the book is the
hardest part about writing it right you
spent two years writing this book like
what she was a most surprising or the
hardest part I would say yeah it's
that's a it's a it's a very good
question on okay I would say I would say
this that when you're writing a memoir
like this is like my fourth draft of the
book and I like deciding what parts of
your career to mention are critical
because books good books are scenes and
measure X books like this and I've
crafted mine that way there's scenes and
what seems you choose to put in is is is
indicative of what story you're trying
to tell what parts your character you're
trying to describe like I'm not my whole
essence isn't boiled down into this book
it's the essence that's most important
to telling this story but you know as a
writer of a memoir you're like pretty
much blind - what is it - what is most
important you have a good you have some
instincts but you have to have an
outside reader because like I had scenes
in this book I probably have the book is
about 270 pages I probably have another
150 pages of like polished finished
content that a good editor like I really
had a brilliant editor she just
convinced me like listen this does not
tell the story this is kind of funny
this is kind of interesting
oh you look kind of good here oh this is
kind of a sordid tale that would be but
it doesn't advance the story and when
you're writing a book you're just trying
to like like I wanted her I wrote this
book so that it would be an easy read
you know I really I knew I thought
crypto people would love it and so far
so good it's been very well received but
but I want mainstream people to read it
and to do that you can't give him a
bunch of technical crap and you can't
bury him in some boring parts of my
early story so I crafted all those parts
of the story that had to do with me but
also could could I could identify - how
I got into crypto why I got into crypto
all that kind of stuff I loved it before
before I end I always let the guest ask
me a question and and we talk about
aliens believer non-believer
[Music]
that's funny I just heard that question
yeah absolutely I mean mathematic
there has to be there has to be aliens
and I and by the way I heard your
Mezrich interview and that I think
that's why I was that's why I was
thinking about that stuff that he talks
about is fascinating that there's a lot
of unexplained phenomena and all that I
can't remember the specifics but yeah
absolutely aliens and I also hope they
don't come while I'm here he uh he
shocked me I didn't realize that he had
written books on aliens yeah me neither
I had no idea I was tempted to go get it
in fact I just you just reminded me yeah
he's fantastic all right what a one
question yet for me to finish up what
was your scariest moment in crypto
scariest moment I don't really have
scary moments for me personally as much
as many people who listen to podcasts
have heard the story one of my partner's
got hacked and our sim swapped and and
then there was a follow-up attack after
he kind of corrected all of that and it
put up better security and he got a text
message one day from somebody who
basically said I'm gonna kidnap your
daughter unless you send Bitcoin to this
address and you can imagine you know I
don't have children but you can imagine
off any father who who gets something
like that there's a bunch of emotions
that come in both from fear from anger
right all this kind of stuff all at once
and so he screenshot it and sent it to
me and basically was like you know what
the [ __ ] and so even though you know it
was a situation where it wasn't directly
at me rather involving me it was
somebody so close to me that that it was
pretty nerve-racking frankly well we
can't end on that so what was a happy
day in crypto for you for sure I
I gotta say that when Bitcoin rallied it
wasn't one day but when Bitcoin rallied
from you know the depths of thirty one
thirty two hundred in December of 2018
back over ten thousand write that out to
me was ten thousand was a big
psychological moment for a lot of people
and I think it kind of reinvigorated
people to look you can pay attention to
these short-term price movements brover
a long period
you know this asset in this network have
all the value and advantages and
everything that we're all excited about
but but to me that was a really big
moment because you know this was a big
big bear market many for many people the
first and so when they kind of see an
asset draw it on 85% like that you know
it's natural to think hey we're going to
zero yeah absolutely though that's
that's a great plan I agree
so all right we're on where can people
go find find the book today it's on
Amazon today it's an audiobook ebook and
a paperback book and so it's confessions
of a crypto millionaire my unlikely
escape from corporate America you can
also find me on Twitter at Dan Conway
six five oh all right man
dan I appreciate it very much the book
is fantastic I have a copy here that is
now inscribed on the front cover it says
pomp I wrote this book for you you
filthy animal so the rest of you felt
the animals go pick it up and then we'll
have to do this again great thanks so
much pomp hey everyone pop here if you
like this episode of off the chain and
want to help us take crypto to the top
of the Apple Spotify and other podcast
charts please do us a favor and rate
review and subscribe to review simply go
to the off-the-chain home page scroll
down until you see the five blank stars
taking 15 seconds to fill those stars in
and leave a quick review goes a long way
and helping us take the entire crypto
ecosystem to the top of the charts I
appreciate you listening and see you
next time on off the chain
you